there were so many good games this year
in fact I bet you there's a game you
love that probably flew under the radar
in the midst of many many many other big
games and I assure you that was the same
case for a lot of us here personally at
Gamespot so much so that we wanted to
take the opportunity to Spotlight some
games that maybe didn't get the light
maybe didn't get the same Limelight as
the big old top 10 that we made but that
doesn't mean that they're any less good
than those ones so in this video we're
gonna go over the games that we hear
Gamespot love that maybe didn't make the
top 10 but meant a lot to us
take it away folks Cult of the Lamb is a
great marriage between Dungeon Crawler
life Sim Farm Sim base Builder resource
management and even though the combat
isn't the most deep it completely
changed how I feel about roguelike games
it was the first game to finally get me
in that one more run just one more run
mode
even though most of my runs weren't even
to get further in a dungeon it was
usually to get more resources for my
villagers or to get a new villager or
even most importantly to get new
decorations from my Village because I
spent way too much time in the
decorating and Base building and stuff
like that
sometimes just to zone out and listen to
the music because let me tell you
the music in Cult of the Lamb slaps this
soundtrack is absolutely fantastic so
beyond the fact that it's super cute it
has a fun gameplay Loop it has a story
that's just interesting enough but
simple enough to not get too crazy then
you also have a soundtrack that like you
can just Lo-Fi beats that you could just
listen to whenever you're doing whatever
I listen to it whenever I'm walking my
dog washing the dishes anything it's on
streaming services
it's really that mix of genres that
helped Cult of the Lamb really stand out
amongst all of the other games I've
played this year you've got the Cozy
Vibes but you also have the creepy Vibes
you have the relaxing and the action and
it all Blends together to create this
really cool stew of a game that just
good soup
it may have not been the game of the
year for Gamespot but it was really
special to me
when I started playing sonic Frontiers
it was kind of as a joke I wasn't really
sure what to expect I had heard you know
good bad middling all-around
but to be honest the more I play it the
more I love it
um it is a combination of death
stranding uh Shadow of the Colossus and
Tony Hawk uh I I love just traversing
the kind of Silent open world
and unlocking the different like
grinding sessions that you can do to
like get from different area to
different area on the island the speed
zones I guess is what they're called
like the the digital zones are some of
the best like modern Sonic stages that
we've had in a very long time so the
game is able to capture sonic speed in a
way that I feel like no modern Sonic
game has been able to do yet especially
when you like level up all of your rings
and it gives you that extra speed boost
it just to me it feels so good to just
zoom around the open island with that in
mind and I think the moment that I I it
clicked was I had that kind of breath of
the wild moment of there was this giant
flying Colossus type creature in the
distance and I looked at that and I was
like I can go fight that I can go do
like I can do that and I like ran as
fast as I could and grind it on a rail
and hit a bunch of rings and was like
flying all over the place and doing
flips and tricks and all that stuff and
then fought that boss I was like I like
this this is this is good I like this a
lot I was thinking about it and it feels
like if the the promises that Sonic 06
made and didn't deliver on are finally
being rectified in Sonic Frontiers and
I've just I've really having a really
really really good time with it and it
may not have made gamespot's top 10 but
it meant a lot to me and I'm really
enjoying my time with it so I wanted to
give a little shout out to Sonic from
tears so evil West is a game that I can
tell you very little about
I cannot tell you the name of the main
character I cannot tell you the name of
the side character who you only see
Standing On Top of rocks and shouting at
you I cannot tell you the name of the
main character's Dad don't ask me about
the story because I don't know it I've
played it for maybe six hours could not
tell you the first thing about it what I
can tell you is if you hold the attack
button
he does a little uppercut and the
enemies go into the air and if you keep
holding it he jumps into the air and
does a Superman punch if you do that in
front of explosive barrels you will
automatically punch your enemy into the
barrels and they will explode into blood
and guts that is one of the most
satisfying things that you will be able
to experience this year in video games
evil West is like a an action game from
I would say 2008 built for the Xbox 360.
maybe the PlayStation 3. and it is
schlocky it's like Gears of War that
kind of
I was gonna say B tier but it's not B
tier Gears of War as AAA game but it's
got that feeling you know that feeling
of like this is arcady It's kind of
loose it's kind of bloody
um and as you keep playing you realize
that there's more mechanics being
introduced each of them feels slightly
broken
each of them feels like they weren't
balanced very well and that's part of
the fun you get an electric leash which
means that you can pull enemies towards
you and then automatically just start
pummeling them and while you're
pummeling them you completely Invincible
no one can do anything to you and then
you get this Dash move which if you hold
the electric button I don't know what
that's all about but it's an electric
button it will teleport towards your
enemies and then you can do that same
flurry of punches or you can hit them
with a shotgun it's ridiculous but it
feels like a goofy dumb
action game that you can play and
immediately have fun with like I
guarantee you play that game it will be
literally a minute before you are having
fun and then from that point on you will
keep having fun and it will keep giving
you dumb things to do and then by the
time you're done the game's over and
you'll be like you know what I did not
expect to have that much fun with this
game
but I had a lot of fun with this game
and although it's not good enough to
make it onto gamespot's top 10 of the
year
it is something that I think that people
should give a shot it's one of my
favorite games of the year evil West
still can't tell you the main
character's name not even if I tried
rollerdrome is one of my favorite games
of 2022 mainly because it's one of the
best games you can play on the best
device of 2022 which is the steam deck
so the game is a mashup between a third
person Arena shooter and Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater and it's amazing how the game
succeeds in both of those regards it is
not only fun to shoot things but it is
also really fun to just roll around the
amount of tricks you can do the weight
of all the systems integrate with one
another so doing tricks will increase
your ammo so you can take out more
enemies and then also the challenges
that are involved everything just works
together so well that by the time you've
played through a level of rollerdrome
you have these additional challenges
that are left that really push you so
you can get through the game pretty
quickly but if the game hooks its claws
into you which it probably will there's
so much left to pull out of it even
though you're still just kind of
replaying the same levels over and over
again I love the variety of enemies and
the way that they force you to approach
different situations there are enemies
that are better at defending so you have
to use a certain type of weapon or you
need to get around them there's hidden
things on the levels as well that also
play into that replay ability it's just
great after years and years of not
getting a really good like skating game
even though this isn't you know a Tony
Hawk skateboarding game that there
haven't there hasn't been a really great
game in this genre in a while and you
know at the heart of it it's just really
fun to play if you were just skating
around of the the gun gameplay just adds
uh another level rollerdrome is a
combination of quake and Tony Hawks Pro
Skater and not only does it succeed at
being both kinds of those games but the
elements of both feed into each other so
well it's kind of maddening that no one
has made a game like this before it's a
game that you can pick up and play and
have a 10 minute experience with or you
can spend literal hours going through
and replaying all the levels to get all
the different hidden items and try all
the different difficulties and complete
all the challenges and so it's just
simply about having a ton of fun and
that is why it is one of my personal
games of the year in 2022.
as someone who's been playing games for
their entire life uh you can really
notice when a developer goes the extra
mile when they put as many little
details they can in to make something
that they're truly passionate about and
for me cuphead the delicious last course
was that game and it didn't just connect
from an artistic standpoint it's
beautiful everyone knows that about
cuphead that's part of what made us
successful but even from a gameplay
standpoint
um as someone who's recently been
delving into a little more game design
and majored in it back way back a long
time ago I really notice a lot of those
things a lot more of just how difficult
it is to design something as tight as
cuphead and the delicious last course
and making something that's difficult
but fair and all of the different
interesting ways that the bosses that
you fight interact with your characters
it's just Immaculate in how well
designed it is from a gameplay
standpoint
and that's just art aside I mean the art
is its own topic when it comes to
cuphead of how beautiful it is and with
the delicious last course they took
everything about the main game but went
the extra step every boss in the
delicious last course has multiple
phases that have so many moving parts
and incredible animations in it it's
just stunning to behold and stunning the
play and every boss has different
gameplay beats and moments where none of
them blend together none of them feel
like you're repeating the same thing
every moment in those boss fights every
phase feels like something completely
new it's just so incredibly well done to
the point where it made me go back and
replay the original cuphead and S rank
multiple missions which I hadn't done
before so S rank is the best that you
can do in cuphead the delicious last
course made me want to do that well in
the DLC and do that well in the main
game itself is that fantastic uh has a
whole new end boss which is incredible
in its own right and a new character you
can play as Miss chalice who at first
took me a while to get used to but once
you do she has her own unique moveset
that makes her incredibly fun to play
and fun to play the original game with
her as well the delicious last course
may not have made the Game Spot top 10
but for me in my heart it's a game that
I will love and cherish and I'm so glad
I got to play this year and if you
haven't I encourage you to especially if
you enjoy platform games action games
bullet hell games or any combination of
those just give it a shot I know it's
difficult but it is worth it
this year we got a parent's Call of Duty
in Modern Warfare 2. and that might
sound a little counter-intuitive when
you're talking about first-person
shooters but there's a lot of us who
grew up playing games and love these
kind of games and we just don't have the
time anymore for like the super fast
jumpy slidey reactions that young kids
have anymore we can't waste a ton of
time losing progress we need those
rewards to come and we need to be able
to walk away from this game when life
calls because if that happens to you all
the time as a parent and this game
strangely enough nailed a lot of those
aspects of a Call of Duty game it is a
game that respects your time in so many
different ways pretty much anything that
you do gives you tons of rewards in that
game but more importantly it's a game
where you can actually think your way
through the levels so like even on the
core maps or in DMZ which I'm really
addicted to in the previous Call of
Duty's it got to the point where it was
almost like fortnite like the most
cracked a kid with the the fastest
slides and the biggest jumps and the
fastest ads would just kill you every
time and it wasn't a pleasant experience
this game made things more grounded it
has shorter shorter time to kill you can
build things to counter those tactics
and you could also just use your brain
you can just memorize the map and you
can just sort of aim at the right places
at the right times and anticipate them
and then watch them cry as they just get
dropped and that is something that I
think parents enjoy very much with very
little time to do these sort of things
now the other aspect of it is war zone
and Warzone is something where you need
to dedicate like maybe like 20 minutes
to it or 30 minutes at a time and when
that last circle is closing and one of
your kid starts crying or like
somebody's punching somebody else in
your house you got to feed a kid dinner
like you need to be able to walk away
from that match and not feel bad about
it and it's brilliant that they put
together DMZ because I think exactly
what DNZ is it's a mode where you can
drop into a war zone match you can fight
other players if you want to you can
basically just fight against the AI you
can rescue people like you know like a
good parent would but you can also just
leave when you need to and the people
who you leave behind can just ask other
people to join them or if your friends
leave you you can just ask other people
to join you Modern Warfare 2 might not
have made gamespot's top 10 list but as
a parent it is hands down one of my
favorite games this year when I need to
play and then I need to run because
something happened with my kid somebody
pooped their pants somebody needs to eat
or I just need to go do homework with my
child so thank you Call of Duty
so potionomics is this darling little
indie game where you play as this potion
maker who's new to the town and you have
to meet everyone so you're talking to
people you're learning new bartering
strategies of how to like sell your
potions and whatnot and as you're
learning these new strategies they are
unlocked as cards that you can just
slide into your deck so that when you do
Brew Your potions when you are trying to
sell these potions to your customers who
are coming in you have to play these
random cars and you have to like play
them in a way where you can get the most
profit possible you're trying to like
force people to give you a little bit
more money to ignore the defects and the
potion that you've crafted you're trying
to get the most money as possible before
their patience runs out and they just
leave the store entirely and that alone
is one of my like favorite things to do
like I have so much time invested into
potionomics already but on top of that
pushinomics is also also like this
visual novel like dating Sam and
everyone in this game is really cute
they're all smoochable from the Burly
walrus dude to the like seder a girl
with a prosthetic Maid of wood to Mint
who's this like cute little uh Knight
who's trying to be an adventurer uh like
from like a d d campaign like type thing
like she's like a starting Adventurer
and she comes to you asking for potions
and advice on how to go out into the
world and you can smooch all of them you
can romance whoever you want and
I love it so much it's my game of the
year even if it didn't make top 10 of
Gamespot it's a game that you really
should be playing if you haven't already
when it comes to horror games I have a
very hard time playing them I am easily
startled easily scared it takes a lot
for me to commit to playing them because
I am a weenie about them that being said
the second that I saw us analysis art I
knew that I needed to play it it just
immediately drew me in and I was like
okay I can suck it up to get through
this game and I'm glad that I did
because it is such a cool game and not
just in the style of it too it also has
substance it feels a lot like this Ode
to these classic PlayStation 1 games
right like the old Resident Evil games
or Silent Hill
um in that it kind of just throws you
into it with you know little explanation
and you're just kind of forced to fight
for your life quite literally
um I think that the art and the sound
design in that game are phenomenal it
really sticks to this particular Vibe
and aesthetic that it wants you to take
away from the experience it uses all of
these like bright Reds and like this
kind of crtv like wavelengthy you know
filter over a lot of it it Harkens back
to to that kind of time period right of
like you know the late 90s PlayStation
games uh beautifully it's a it's a
really fantastic Love Letter to these
games but it also takes them and
transforms them into something for
modern day in modern players I think
that overall as you play signalus it
does a really good job of empowering you
as a player when you solve all these
different puzzles that it throws at you
and and Wade through these hallways of
these you know alien life forms that
keep coming back to life so it's like
you never get out of that that tension I
think it does a really good job of
making you feel like you've accomplished
something as if you are kind of living
through that story living through that
struggle
um in a way that you know horror games
tend to do but to do it so artistically
and so beautifully is really an
impressive feat and that's why even
though it might not be one of gamespot's
top 10 games of the year signalis is
definitely worth playing in 20 22.
one of my favorite co-op games of the
last decade is overcooked I think that
game is just so brilliant in the way it
encourages cooperation between the
players as you're trying to cook these
meals so when I saw this game called
plate up I was like oh okay it's uh it's
it's an overcooked clone that's that's
cool maybe I'll check it out what I
wasn't expecting is a game that takes
the like base ideas of overcooked and
then like completely evolves it and it
ends up becoming a very different
experience that I found myself
completely addicted to and me and my
partner ended up putting 30 plus hours
into it take overcooked and you turn it
into a roguelike you and your partner
now have to run a restaurant and so
every day you have to manage certain
aspects of it you essentially need to
self assign yourself roles so you could
say all right I'm gonna be the waiter my
partner is going to be the chef death
and they're going to be in the kitchen
in the back and I'm going to be the ones
bringing the customers in asking them
their orders and serving them layout of
the building is randomized that's part
of the roguelike element but then you
get to take like you know the tables and
you get to take the the kitchen
appliances you get to move them around
and then also every day you are given a
series of blueprints that are randomized
that can potentially improve your
restaurant so oh hey now we got a
dishwasher or we got a improved burner
you go through each day and it gets
harder and harder and harder you have to
strategize where your deficiencies and
okay the kitchen's going fine but I'm
getting absolutely swamped by the amount
of tables so we need to try and get more
tables we need to try and upgrade the
tables and pray to the RNG gods that we
get a good table that we need and we
don't get like a [ __ ] roll because it's
a roguelike of course making it random
it it can add a level of frustration but
also so has just like so much more
variety and you find yourself like being
like no one more run this is the one
we're gonna do it it's a game that I
don't think that many people know of you
know that's that's probably why I didn't
end up in game spots top 10 of 2022 but
it's a game that meant a lot to me and
my partner personally in the 30 plus
hours we put into it so it's certainly
one of my favorite games of the year
I know what all of you are thinking out
there power wash the simulator you want
to talk about power washer simulator yes
I do I am excited to talk about power
washer simulator it is freaking amazing
when we talk about video games we tend
to like have a leaning towards
discussing big moments and epic Journeys
and amazing gameplay that just knocked
our socks off and that's all definitely
worth talking about but I think we
forget how important it is to have games
that allow us to sort of process a lot
of the emotions that we're feeling in
the world right now and one of the
feelings that I feel a lot of the time
when I look out in the horrible world
that we live in right at the moment is
anxiety I I feel a lot of deep anxiety
about the world and one of the things
that I go to video games for is to help
me process those emotions in a really
healthy way and I I am not joking about
this power washer simulator was one of
those games that really helped me
process a lot of my anxiety this year I
would sometimes just sit down at the end
of the day feeling like really nervous
and worried about all the things that I
had to deal with and I would just put on
power washing simulator and just start
cleaning off a fire truck or like a
fantasy like shoe house uh and I don't
know it just it brought me a sense of
relaxation and almost meditation in a
way that I I actually legitimately do
think is deeply valuable today we don't
really give ourselves enough time to
just sit and be and take comfort in just
making things clean like making things
just nice and presentable and I think
that that's honestly kind of just I I
don't know I found it really rewarding
and I found it actually really helpful
this year and for me I think power
washer simulator definitely has to go as
one of my favorite games this year
specifically because it gave me that
valuable moment that I don't think I
would have gotten any other way I think
any game that allows us just to take a
moment and be with ourselves and think
about ourselves is is a really valuable
experience so while it may seem like you
know kind of humorous to talk about
power washer simulator as a great game
of the year I think you'd be missing
something if you didn't take value in
what power washer simulator as a game
can give you and that is why power
washer simulator is one of my favorite
experiences and games this year
trying to explain saturnalia is like
trying to explain a nightmare I've had
it's like going through a convoluted
environment that just never seems to end
with twisting halls and narrow corridors
that goes in every single direction and
you can barely see anything that's in
front of you but you are just running at
all times for your life Non-Stop and
that is really what saturnalia is like
saturnalia is a roguelike horror game
set in a small town in the 80s where you
and a group of other characters
basically realize that something's a
foot and you are going to be running for
your life to escape the thing that makes
the game so terrifying is that the world
is this convoluted mess and once you
think you figure out you've memorized it
it then gets deeper and then you realize
there's this whole other world you have
to learn and this whole other building
you have to deal with and all this is
kind of to create this nightmarish
feeling that you're not ever comfortable
despite how much how well you think you
know the environment and how well you
think you're traversing it while running
away from a terrifying thing that you
can barely see that
you always feel a little lost and that's
that feeling that like it's that feeling
of even when you think you figured it
all out there's something there around
the corner or at least it gives the
feeling that something is there around
the corner there's so many horror games
where it strips you of your ability to
defend yourself and the other side of
that are survival horror is where it
gives you just enough to be able to
think you can make your way out of a
situation and saturnalia is this
beautiful combination of the two where
instead it's your ability to emotionally
regulate yourself in extreme situations
of stress and it does so also by being a
detective game the entire time just as
convoluted as the world you explore are
the clues in which you have to find
around the world to be able to
eventually escape with everyone alive
and there's also this one really cool
element just this thing that I'm
obsessed with that if one of the
characters is taken by this entity
you're running away from it will follow
the scream of that person through the
world to the next character you can play
giving you an opportunity to track this
screen and free that player and it's
just like this kind of marvelous way of
taking a roguelike but still like not
making everything randomized in fact the
only real roguelike element to it is
that once if all your characters are
captured then the entire world resets
and that's an absolute terrifying thing
I don't want to have to deal with ever
because it already is a nightmare trying
to Traverse that place
now it's not a perfect game in fact it
didn't make game spots top 10 but it
left art incredibly lasting impression
on me one that
is as close to a nightmare as I'm
willing to get close to and a nightmare
that I actually kind of enjoy reliving
I've played a lot of games this year
play a lot of games every year and one
of the things that I really really
appreciate is when a game just knows
what it is and feels really good to play
and in tinykin they have all of these
systems that come together but also the
fact that motion feels really good
because you are this big you are
basically the size of an ant and you are
dropped uh you're an astronaut and you
are dropped into a house that's kind of
modeled from a house from the 90s so it
definitely has that borrowers that Toy
Story kind of feel you can't do much by
yourself and so what you do is you
gather and if you've played Pikmin you
will completely understand the core
concept of this game you gather these
little creatures called tinykin and
together they can break down obstacles
for you they can become little towers
they can make stairs for you they can
even run electrical currents around
things and then it is the mix of you
interacting with everyday items in
different ways but it feels so good
while you're doing it so you can Glide
around you can you Glide around also in
the air with a little bubble pack but
you also Glide around on a bar of soap
it is difficult for me to get across how
good that feels when you're in a massive
open level and you know you have to go
over here to collect something you have
to go over there to open this new thing
so it feels so good and tinykin is so
full of charm the puzzles are kind of
like the level of puzzles that I want to
play on a Sunday afternoon like my head
is not all there I'm basically gearing
up for the week I just want to
experience a very delightful easy to
play game I want to complete puzzles I
want to collect things I want to get
that feeling of accomplishment that's
what tinykin has in Spades it might not
have been in gamespot's top 10 games of
the year list but I absolutely adore
tinykin it is one of my favorite games I
played this year in many ways Xenoblade
Chronicles 3 feels like the culmination
of monolith soft it is massive sprawling
ambitious the combat is deep and and
varied you can play as all the
characters in your party and you can
change their class and you can use a
bunch of different moves and fight a
bunch of different enemies across this
incredibly detailed vast world with a
great story that pulls you along
throughout the entire way but I think
what stands out most to me with
Xenoblade Chronicles 3 are the
characters I mean you spend a hundred
Plus hours exploring that world getting
to know these people and what's cool is
your party isn't just limited to your
party there's a bunch of Heroes as well
that also have these great story lines
that interweave throughout the narrative
and just create this incredible story
with a bunch of twists and a bunch of
memorable characters that's just that
that's lifted up by some of the best
combat that the series has ever had I
mean I the combat is hardwired in my
head like I constantly think about going
back to that game and just fighting some
of those bosses again doing some of
those more challenging dungeons that you
can only find once you beat the game so
I don't want to spoil anything but there
is one character interaction in
particular that happens pretty late in
the game that really cemented it as one
of my favorites of 2022 uh the way it
introduced a specific character back
into the fold I thought was super
powerful and really meaningful
especially you know if you've put in 70
80 hours to get to that moment it was
just kind of I don't want to say worth
it all because the entire Journey was
great but that moment in particular will
stick with me for a very long time it is
the most special game for me of this
year
and there you have it now maybe a game
that you love didn't make this list but
hey now's a good opportunity to put them
in the comments because we always need
games to play with that being said enjoy
what you enjoy just go find those games
you love don't care if they make the big
old list just love it love the medium as
it's meant to be loved by all of us okay
until next time
see you later